yo wats of Gaza's prestige here with the
second episode of the feed the beast
survival series that I've been doing
with Nick can say yeah like so yeah
we've moved and we made this is the
inside of the house with the nick made
the household awesome looking and not a
crab shack so that's cool thank you Nick
and yeah so we have a nice house I'm
planning on or we're planning on making
this greater just because it must be
better but yeah Nick made a corn farm
and today we are going to attempt at
making a automated tree farm so am
basically got all this stuff and also
i'm going to show you guys how to make a
almost pretty much infinite power source
okay yeah basically teleport lava from
the nether use lavas power there you go
alright so we're gonna make some so for
this we're gonna need many things but
first off we're going to start off with
the basic the fertilizer my corn is done
oh my gosh that's probably way more than
enough fertilizer making probably won't
need to use his other stack of appetite
all right oh my gosh I have one two
three four five six a little over six
stacks of fertilizer now we now we take
the fertilizer and we cover it in dirt
and we get ourselves hummus that's two
stacks of hummus okay I'm giving more
dirt listen yeah I guess wondered you
just draft 48 fertilizer okay well i
have lots more yeah okay so yeah this
would do it definitely will definitely
have enough fertilizer for many other
days many other days it's going through
that then over there
and okay there we go now we have lots of
hummus we have more than the hummus so
we're good at let's throw all of it
we're not going to use any of this
anymore so all of that I've got some
saplings and we're getting some saplings
so let's make the logger so for a logger
we need all of this stuff the loggers
going to be chopping down the trees so
we guess we need some glass we got some
glass Nick can you make can you put
bronze in the shape nope not bronze oh
yeah bronze in the shape of a chest so
we're gonna yes I can so where's yous
all we need these so we're gonna need a
thermionic fabricator sturdy casing oh
yeah all right here you go thermionic
fabricator and for that we need oh we're
sorting actually can you make another
one ever need multiple um yeah I think I
can only make one more but i canna
bronze so we're need if you need another
one um not right now but thank you for
gold I was at glass yeah we need three
glass so I can I have some of that some
of the classic out I take 12 glass what
the deuce want ok it's all good ok I
took 20 class
and then put the chest there don't boom
we got a therm ionic and I think once I
place this down all I'm going to be only
feeling one able to use it Nick what is
that I'm sure doing its owner about me
it's got going to be used in making some
of the goods so we can go back to the
logger so longer so we need diam and
time electron tube so that we need five
at DIA moans redstone and it gives it
some ten bronze runs ingot silver and
get what it works so we're gonna eat
diamonds Nick can I get it for actually
I've sometimes so I think I've sometimes
so many dumbs dude the dude just take
one of mine man okay and 50 so AC nick
is completely fully loaded so this
series will be easy for resources I go
hard are we need win five diamonds we
needed to redstone was it to redstone
right so I think you go somewhere its
own yeah Nicolas crafting table in here
I mean I didn't gem table since we're
asking about that earlier yeah so let's
see we got our red so now we're also
gonna need like a tin ingot I cannot
supply that with my nothing um refined
iron nickel silver silver works at least
I said it did so I think we put this
here okay I really have no idea what
this stuff how that all this of this all
work so that doesn't work why doesn't it
work oh we Nick we need liquid glass I
got this man okay boys I'm gonna make my
power source now could we need liquid
gila glass I know I'm gonna make the
power source real quick come hither I'll
calm down what liquid that liquid Ghazni
click putting liquid nitrogen oh my gosh
I need to make the liquid glass with my
beautifulness first I need to make the
power source Matt wait you know me how
to make liquid glass what doesn't tell
me how to make liquid gas yeah make
liquid glass you need to use the what is
it I believe it's called the magma
crucible do we have up yeah i have it i
just need to make my power source for
all right well we're gonna this is the
transfer part where we need something
for the good ol the gold tree farms
we're going to see Nick make his power
source obviously I had this planned you
see these are these are these iron
blocks at the moment Nik Nik mat if
you're talking i cannot hear you why why
can't you hear me cuz my skype is
lagging too hard oh well I think okay
for everybody so he has this thing and I
think these are iron blocks another iron
black Sarah what's it called iron tank
walls iron tank walls and when he puts
them all together in a certain formation
they create a one giant entity of iron
tank so while he's building that I think
I can get started on the other part
which is that plant stall the seat
arbitrary and actually we can build we
can build a carpenter so I'm going to
get to that since we're going to need
that for both parts as well carpenter
now with carpenters made it get some
heart we whoa wow we need a lot of rods
you have some prawns yeah I put some in
my chest which chest you look for that
beautiful chest copper copper bronze ok
so I'm hopefully this will be enough
guys hopefully you will
there we go started casing and then
carpenter we're going to need all we
have some glass Oh what was that what
was that recipe just forgot okay so so
like that's why not sure I put it there
yeah that should be enough and then
searched Casey and boom carpenter are
awesome you got it we got ourselves a
carpenter and you owned by me so we can
throw and makes a bronze back in there
and so for we need we're gonna make two
of whatever i'm going to make this into
a basic circuit boards so let's just get
10 and redstone plus we need water
bottles so let's make that three water
three bottles and use water so i can
actually just put up at that water
bucket water bucket that would go and
place you in there and there we go so
since we're we will need to sew or again
me at the carpenter we need to put water
bucket the water bottle are awesome and
now we need more redstone and in Nikki
okay if I take them 10 yeah go ahead I'm
pretty sure I just need two pieces
carpenter and then we smack that tune in
to what though that decades glitch and
hard I've just duplicated 10 everybody
don't worry only that up okay the carpet
wat won't why can happen anything in the
carpenter if you are stuck with the
remaining liquid machines thank you can
click the tank with a pipe night at 10p
it don't need more water no recipe no
match Miss be for the found Oh what
maybe I need to
hmm I have no idea to make have to do
well I was wrong button I have no idea
how to do this our board I yeah so yeah
basic circuit board we need amount one
capacity 10 and then 10 10 and get 10 to
any form of 10 and redstone carpenter
why is this other piece of tinsel here
oh damn it the power source is going ok
one sec I don't understand I can't place
stuff in the carpenter I'll go go just
take a quick glance at nicks power
source and there we go and now you see
it is filling with lava because he has
his previous setup from the lava before
and yeah that'll be so Nick can you get
working on liquid glass while I try and
figure this out yeah I got this I just
do not know I don't know what this stuff
is doing I have to clear out a room real
quick though man ok well oh wait
actually guys I might oh gosh guys guys
I might oh I did it guys guys don't
worry god I don't know how to get it
guys guys ok Nick so I have it I don't
know how to get teh don't know how to do
what like it's in the crap it's in the
little crafting interface but I don't
know how to take it pick it up it's not
allowing me to right there yeah
so I had to place all the stuff down by
a right by left-clicking it so it didn't
actually place the blocks but you have
to power this machine do you know I know
it doesn't say I need to some reason I
feel like you have to power it ok I've
it shared I don't think you do so just
put some water in it and then I'm like
ninety-nine percent sure you need to
power that Matt ok so I need an engine
or just power it off a generator engine
or generate anak that's a generator you
have top tables eek what do you have
copper cables oh yeah I knew ok except
you can't power that with the copper
cable you need an electric engine here
you go and you're gonna need a lover
temporary neon light dark light no I'm
not a sisterly and clone there you go
not a sterling under my Stirling engine
is not good enough yeah it like glued to
it so do Cole that cold be beneficial
first off ok I want some torches
seriously bro I want some torture there
we go let the light shine it now we're
just going to take this call its back
here and we're going to use it to power
machine
so we're going to throw you in there
sure hopefully this works and nope that
didn't work now you go to place it here
make how am I supposed to place the
lever yeah as you can see this is a very
I'm very new at this and nick is nick is
more a little more acquainted because
you play tekkit Ivan late equis you're
doing room what's I assumed I was I
don't know how to do it though oh ok ok
place in a generate or so let's put a
little coal in that generate or how that
way up and then tell this is this is
some complicated doohickeys you see it's
filling out ok was ok sure I'm sold this
all make sense to me there we all I got
one guys don't worry see I told you I
was alright can you can you so do you
have the thingy to make liquid glass out
of not yet I'm building it I just have
to clear out the power room first all
right we got two basic circuit boards so
that's good so we can just delete all
thats and there we go and throw I don't
want this I don't want this was the
other bottle whatever ok so what are we
so for this or we need the liquid glass
for the these things we need liquid
glass
dang this up is expensive that you might
want to pause the video and then restart
it when I get the machine hooked up a
request hardcore entertain however our
guys will be back once Nick is all good
and we have the liquid glass you know
what's up guys the prestige and we're
back again we got all the supplies we
need to make our lager and arbol rekha
more something so basically what I had
to do with the thermic the thermionic
fabricated was put some glass up in this
top left to melt it then make whatever I
want to make and we powered it you can
see this is all renditions done by Nick
the geothermal stuff and I'll yell that
and yeah so we are going to head over to
a crafting table and we should have all
the needed supplies so sturdy casings
and I'm pretty sure I put glass like
this that right yep and then we just
throw it doesn't really matter what
order we do it in I'll just do that so
there we go we got an arboretum and then
we put the DME team or whatever I don't
know then we get the locker so we are
good to go so throw that threw that in
there and we have some chess with us for
clicking materials nick is it night time
yeahh shall we sleep yeah our and also
we have another silent guest joining us
again if you guys if any of you okay
gonna make a liar out of you mad it's
not nighttime um yeah if any of you have
been suppose even nighttime Matt I lied
to your face I just uh oh my gosh Nick
if any of you guys have been subscribed
for the super long time from ml tandem
you you've probably seen Joe are a few
times so this is Joe and I don't think
he's gonna talk but that's okay and yeah
he's callin dating too hard he is
playing call of duty that is true so
when you're going to place the arboretum
right there and the logger right next to
it and then we are going to need to
charge them with the Stirling engines
that's a fail Matt are you [ __ ] what
do you see that engine yeah I know wait
toys I'll be back going I actually know
what I fixed it ok you're just breaking
replace it or what no I have a rent ok I
was gonna go get a wrench I have to run
choosing ok so we have both of those and
then we never it never it with it is
that lever not gonna work neither lovers
going to work because they don't have
power going to them why they don't have
power going to the engines I'm gonna put
coal in the engines don't worry so we're
gonna fill this with who miss and then
we're going to put in our SAP Elaine's
think the sand it'll create on its own
so first we're going to want to turn on
these this engine so let's put some cold
air inlets their workouts turn on so
that should start placing the hummus in
a like some formation around us like 16
6 by 6 to the round let me turn my
render distance down a bit so you guys
get a little bit of friend oh it placed
a piece of home and see oh so the more
magical the more power we give it the
more it will go and so it's going to
need to do that and then it's also going
to need to place saplings and once the
saplings grow we can just turn the
logger on we don't really need to keep
the logger going try to turn on the
logger for some reason it won't go on I
had some power in it what I didn't put
any coal in it cuz we don't need it why
can't I get into the logger could maybe
cuz I built it Oh
oh you can't get into the logger like
you don't get into the logger now except
i want to i think this will work just
because the logger is it will be getting
power so i'm going to place a chest here
since the logger should it's okay this
should work now i'm wondering if the
arboretum will have to plant all the
hummus and then Matt just pause it until
the hummus is although oh wait no
nevermind it's placing trees I don't
matter okay that's cool it's cool ours
actually we are going to i'm gonna get
some a bone meal and we're gonna make
the trees good i got it ok naman nick
nick is just super prepared dude i was
born ready all right so he's gonna throw
that on I lied it doesn't work what
doesn't work on the trees ok well then
I'm pretty sure they grow fast on humna
so that'll be good and this thing is
planting them like there's no tomorrow
so that's awesome and yeah so it'll make
this hummus thing then the logger we'll
just chop it down so that's basically it
we can also do it with rubber trees and
then we have an extractor thing if we
want to attract the rubber but right now
we just want some good old good old wood
so we're gonna have that as that so yeah
automatic tree farm will probably come
back to this in an episode or two to
show you guys the progress made now I
think because we already had 15 minutes
and is there anything else you want to
do in this episode um my mom no oh wait
wait yes yes come here what I'm putting
some stuff in my chests cuz I don't need
okay what i've read wood plank um what
look you too Jess that makes the case
what do you want first everybody has to
look at my beautiful staircase
architecture very beautiful till they've
seen it but all right and then my
everybody needs to take a moment of uh
you know silence in look at my beautiful
corn farm oh yeah oh my gosh is so
beautiful wait I got this okay that's
fully grown corn for you so probably
gonna make an automatic farm harvest
sure that is something you don't you do
not need all this super super cool thing
is for you just need plane or playing
good old minecraft redstone and pistons
I feel like they should have already
come out with a machine that is an
automatic quorum harvester that would be
to ministry understandable alright so
yeah hopefully the tree is I really want
to be one of these trees to grow cuz i
want to show by the lolla guy in action
just pause the video and go back to it
when it's done everything huh I'll take
some hardcore editing skills Nick
hardcore dueling skills that I will
already have beening dude I believe in
you ah actually I know what I wanted to
do this episode alright guys but I know
what I'm gonna do don't worry I'm gonna
make some skylights hoo-ha skylights Oh
skylights I just think I said
okay don't respond whatever Nick what I
didn't hear you oh my gosh did you say
something no it's not okay good I was
lying he just thought i did say
something what did you say Shh let it
happen totally alright so this is
actually gonna require many many many
well I'm same money just lots of
different well here's an altar whoa oh
all this thing ow Nick it's one of your
does that Bhima Dula electric electric
boys angry I think these drop diamond so
it's oh gosh I don't think they do okay
well then let's kill me I'll take him
out ow no double team you Nick die die
they're flying they're running out the
one the one slope here okay okay nope no
no no not gonna die I could die not
gonna die again yeah I will laugh so
head ahead two hearts are nectar they
keep spawning yeah zappy medulla I come
get okay bye-bye al al Rahman and too
powerful they are very powerful so this
will be mine this will be the skylight
so I'm gonna probably going to make a
lot of these I'll just be showing you
guys this first one I'll make either one
just off camera it's not the most fun
stuff I still fighting the Nick no it's
me in my is being me good yeah I know
cuz you're going to talk in the sub
certain up
well let's say doesn't know you're gonna
fall and then you're gonna die do you
forget that my armor protects from like
awful is it like charged or something um
the everything's that the chest plate
has partial charge because the only
thing that protects you from falling is
the boots well I have charged boots I'm
gonna go charge mine I forgot that we
already set up everything yeah we can
charter stuff also even though I just
set it up like 10 seconds ago so yeah so
guys are the stuff that nyx aboard am I
even at the thing what what the I don't
even know if I'm I'm mind year you're
going down the right like in the back of
the walls so I'm not in the overhang no
crap you're not you're like 10 miles
away fail okay then why was that was a
fail biggest one I've ever seen I'm
gonna set a waypoint waypoints anyway
points um skylights okay it's kind of
like failed but whatever skylights so
we're going to go back up actually up on
the trees have grown so we can't do
anything over there and go back up the
other problem you long episode so you
guys can enjoy the length dude length
itude you heard I don't believe that's a
word alright so I'm going to have to
sprint past these electrodes because
they took good and provide a range
weapon be easier to kill him probably
there may or many of them have spawn I
knew them respond when Abram dude
go go go or I'm going to track both of
them aren't I probably ow ow Nick
support wired go away go with my spot
one waking with skylight think I got
deep enough so they won't attack me
these guys make some freaking noises so
hopefully this will make it yeah I just
don't know how many are blocks I'll be
taught to go down gangsta rap that's how
many blocks Hannah can you estimate the
gap from the roof of our house to the
ceiling like how many blocks it is 34
blocks ok are you so confident that
answer gonna question me all the time
I'm just asking but ok question me all
the time kind of your dude Oh
a few people here that loudness is my
penance apologies skyla yes that's
number numero uno so we'll make many
more of those have any trees still not
grown and I k so don't take it to fall
down okay all the hummus is planted but
we do not have enough trees for Thea to
completely fill the other stuff so our
guys I hope you've enjoyed this video if
you got this far this is always my thing
there's always my mindset someone gets
to the end of one of my videos
especially when my longer videos I feel
like like you guys are like really
enjoyed the that's nice that is yeah I
feel like you guys really enjoy it if
you got that far so if you did please
like comment rate and if you're new
subscribes and i'll be doing other stuff
so we like this stuff then subscribe I
ballabh is going to all the place donec
I know I fixed it good job full of lava
nice so I hope you all enjoyed this much
so and yeah so my name is Christy your
stooge that's Joe and Sofia so at five
mode well let's give it a good look at
my face goodbye to all you lovely people
yeah